another thing going on in Italy is this
climate act this is this is really wild
and shows you how out of control these
people are uh climate activists you may
have seen this uh jumped into Rome's
Trevi Fountain which is a legendary
found in Rome I've been there and they
poured black diluted chemicals in the
water to protest climate change I don't
think Maloney is going to stand for this
climate activists turn the Blue Waters
of the famous Trevi Fountain Black by
dumping charcoal into it the protest was
aimed at the Italian government and its
use of fossil fuels as historic floods
ravaged parts of the country all all of
the activists were arrested officials
say they'll now have to drain the
fountain entirely throwing out 66 000
gallons of water
and disappointing a lot of tourists you
see how the media even frames it that
it's somehow the drought and now the
floods and that that somehow has to do
with fossil fuels there's just no
evidence of any of this nonsense
[Music]